and the grammy goes too
kiss me more
[Applause]
baby
[Applause]
[Music]
what happened and how are you doing and
how did you walk in those heels well i
fell out the bed it sounds foolish but i
thought about the bed but like when
you're already asleep your cognition is
not where it should be so i couldn't
like catch myself the way that i should
i'm clumsy oh but you're also a grammy
winner how does it feel to win and how
did you how did you get up and walk in
those hills necessity no not just i
don't know just the power of god and i
was trying to get there because i didn't
want dojo to miss her word either so i
was just trying to hold the plates
bro you went to the bathroom for five
minutes are you serious
[Music]
come on now
listen
[Music]
i have never taken
such a fast
piss
in my whole life
thank you
everybody
[Applause]
i really appreciate it
congratulations thank you so much that's
good seeing you
thank you dojo thank you to my mama
thank you to god and just thank all of
y'all i'm glad you made it back in time
[Music]